hey guys how's it going it's Justine
happy Cinco DeMayo of course to
celebrate we're gonna be making tiny
tacos today and the first time I did one
of these little yummy nummy videos years
ago it was like the most fun I've had in
a really long time and not sure why I
don't really know if I enjoy it the food
isn't even that good and it kind of
smells funny but for whatever reason
they are really fun to make but this is
meat tiny taco meat how's that gonna
taste I already know how it's gonna
taste it's not gonna taste good it all
smells a little lime a drink
ooh spicy let's get started got all of
our things here see here's the problem
usually I do this with two people and
they'll read the directions well I try
to figure out what's happening so now
that I'm alone I got to read it myself
remove the tray packets and utensils
from packaging use a scissor to cut
we've got our scoops we've got our
spoons got our little teeny-tiny class
chute open the tortilla oh nine zero
package here's the tortilla package
disgusting six round scoops one six and
then we do two square waters okay now
we're gonna mix this up got our little
dough here now we're gonna separate this
into two little sections and we're gonna
jam this into our little taco template
fifteen seconds on the clock Oh done
this smells like something that no one
should ever eat but guess what I'm gonna
eat it and so is Nick what what what now
we're getting into the meat guys we need
four scoops of meat powder let's open up
our meat bag four scoops of taco meat
one for three squares of water three
squares of water all right to mix up
this meat Wow wait
wait a minute we have to microwave this
tray for 10 seconds then immediately
begin chopping up the taco meat within
the tray using your spoon so the meat
looks ground up immediately start
chopping I'm thinking of a song it goes
a little something like doo-doo-doo I
want to meet that Dad doo-doo-doo what's
that Dad like so we're gonna put our
meat inside of there next we are making
the taco sauce - Skitz sauce one scoop
of water doesn't that look delicious
Nick is throwing up over there as we
speak
now we are scooping the oh I didn't make
the cheese mixture I was supposed to do
a cheese mixture oh okay well there's
also a cheese mixture I skipped a step
oh wow that smells like delicious one
and you go the cheese mixture is being
mixed it smells just like like instant
mac and cheese mix so we're supposed to
scoop in the cheese and mixtures into
this little bag I think that's that's
not necessary we're just gonna dump it
in mmm
thanks your saucier
looks very good oh I gotta make the
drink one little scoop of the fizzy
drink powder so I'm just gonna put a
little and I'm not gonna measure cuz I
really am NOT about that measuring life
or sit-ups listen they're fizzy fizzy
fizzy fizzy cocoa puffs pass it to me
now drink it up and don't know it's
fizzing look at this does this not look
like the most delicious meal that you've
ever seen now we have to eat it
Sierra and I'm checking over here do you
want to be on camera here's my cheesy
cheesy taco that's your non cheesy taco
okay cheers to the freakin weekend happy
Cinco DeMayo
[Music]
Curtis I mean it surprisingly tastes
like yeah yeah it's really not bad but I
wouldn't say it's good it's really
sticky the tortillas like gooey did you
say you want the rest of this is she's
not you like cheese like cheese thank
Jesus
no we're doing shots go ahead you up
yeah no it's busy drink it tastes like a
flat spray
well happy Cinco DeMayo happy mini Cinco
de Meyer to you - did you enjoy it yeah
it was great it was so worth it it was
so worth however long it took me to make
this which actually was a lot longer
than I thought it'd be okay oh yeah
I'll see you guys in my next video thank
you guys so much for watching whoo guys
have a wonderful singer 2-mile let me
know if you guys would like me to make
something like this again I think I
enjoyed it I'm pretty sure I did I
didn't enjoy the taste but I enjoyed the
process I will see you guys later bye
[Music]
you
[Music]